j'ai toujours le meilleur compréhension
[Musique]
je ne fais pas mais qu'elle faisait là
tous ensemble heureux en bonne santé ce
cadeau là peuvent offrir jusqu'à les 120
ans
je fais avec grand chose
[Musique]
quand j'ai fait pour en arriver
quel c'est toi la star de la commune
j'aurais été la star citait pègre
[Musique]
j'adore seek amy
c'est possible qu'on leur trouve jamais
charlotte
on l'a retrouvé une gamine qui s'évapore
sur une route sans témoin ce mec ne fait
pas d'erreur tu sais où elle est la
petite
ça fait 20 ans qu'ils passent entre les
mailles du filet comment on fait pour
point c'est un type qui fait pas
d'erreur je suis sûr que ce type a fait
d'autres victimes
je veux la retrouver un tout prix
[Musique]
tu as à voir
non
j'arrive j'arrive je sors deux secondes
six jeux à l'école c'est comme ça j'ai
failli mourir quatre gars c'est pourquoi
je suis un [ __ ] c'est ça parce que je
suis son père et je veux pas qu'on ait
coupé couilles mais moi je suis maire je
veux pas qu'ils se comprennent plus voir
ce que c'est la vraie vie pour gaston
sébilleau fivaz y allait rentrer à la
maison à pied
je veux juste que mon bébé avait bien
une chance qu'ils acceptent comme inès
et ça a pris
marach
l'invasion
je suis de votre nouveau prof de
français je crois que des fds maintenant
alors c'est toi c'est moi quoi la tête
de con il y en a toujours une au boulot
ce lieu là c'est un endroit des changes
et de respect quand je pense de toi
paraît que je dois vous noté alors et
moi pour hp si vous pensez à gagner le
respect des élèves c'est raté j'ai
changé quelques méthodes c'est une
banque pas comme sa part du boulot c'est
pas bien d'être prof ça fait deux jours
commence par les partis sont les
segments
il est pas pris d'affaires il répond pas
au téléphone faut lancer un avis de
recherche
on va devoir forer dans votre vie privée
et professionnelle
mais j'ai rien à cacher nous espérons
que votre mari non plus
[Musique]
doit démarrer dès fois on retrouve le
rien est très belle
on disparaît pas comme ça sans raison
[Musique]
le truc vous et surdoué 162 qi au
potentiel intellectuel hpi recherche de
file être cinq
évitant tout essayé j'ai été embauché
par les flics de france 17 à voir dans
l'oeuf
sur ce que je veux dire
deux trois coups quoi mais quoi la baie
vous aller défoncer la porte alors moi
je vous soutiens moralement aller en
france et sur les postes est toujours le
meilleur compétiteur et là tous ensemble
heureux en bonne santé ce qu'est l'open
offrir jusqu'à mes cent vingt ans
je fabrique en choses
[Musique]
quand j'ai fait pour en arriver
quel c'est toi la star de la commune
j'aurais été la star citait peur
[Musique]
j'adore seek amy
je me suis vengé je me suis vengé du
cher avait kidnappé son fils
je l'étranglé hijri j'étais à la pologne
ma vengeance et crêpes
à deux clans les pros la roche sont et
christine et les pros christian son
entier la revue
t'ordonne pas trois jours pour
comprendre que christine lundi le
corbeau est l'assassin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]